- I'm gonna die.
(laughs)
(intense music)
- [Voiceover] P90x is a fitness program
that provides the ultimate
alternative to the gym.
The program lasts 90 straight days,
designed to get participants
in the best shape of their lives.
So, we got four ordinary people
to try the latest version.
- I'm hoping that it makes me a fitter,
healthier person after this.
- I feel like this will
be a good change-up.
I also expect to look like
Beyonce by the end of this.
- I just haven't really been as active
as I used to be in college.
So, I think now is the
time to make a change.
- I think I'm gonna I'm gonna be,
like, lean mean fighting machine.
Really buff.
Hopefully still womanly buff.
But I think it's gonna work.
- [Mallory] I'm kind of nervous that
they're gonna tell me I'm obese.
- Gonna confirm what I already know
that I'm a lazy piece of shit.
- Like a lazy piece of shit.
(all laugh)
- [Voiceover] We're all fat.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, but this
will be really helpful though,
to see where we're at, so that we know
kind of where we want to go.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, that's right.
And then get checked again
and then realize that,
you know, we're so fit.
- Yeah, we're gonna be badass babes.
- Right.
- [Daysha] He told me that I need to lose
about 20 pounds of body fat.
I'm only more excited
to do this P90X thing
because I think that there's more progress
to be made from here.
- Well according to this
I only have 8.8% body fat.
So I need to stop doing that
and I guess focus on just gaining muscle.
- I did not know that I have
to lose 18 pounds of fat.
That is a very large infant.
- I don't really work out
more than anybody here.
I'd say they probably all
work out more than me.
So I get it. I'm an asshole.
(intense music)
- Let's pray for no one to die today.
- What the hell?
- Okay.
(laughter)
- What?
(grunting)
- Your leg's up the whole time?
(grunting and laughing)
- [Voiceover] This feels weird!
- My lungs are in my ass!
- My calves are on fire.
My shins are on fire.
(grunting)
- The grunting! Ryan!
(mock grunting)
(laughter)
- I can't focus.
- I need to do it! Shut up!
(grunting)
- I'm just gonna pull.
(cries out, then laughs)
- It's been tough.
- [Kenny] I feel like I've
had more energy overall.
- [Voiceover] I would
say this is up there,
maybe top five worst
decisions I've ever made.
- It's been going like really well.
Even just a week after doing
stuff, I could feel my abs.
- [Kenny] But I've
definitely noticed like,
well, my shirt fits a little better.
- 90 days, it's insane.
I don't know how anybody could do this
without being forced to.
- I can already tell, to be honest.
- Ooh. Checking yourself out?
- Of course!
(grunting and laughter)
- You're not even sweating!
- I am sweating!
- Look at my face!
- [Ryan] So, I just did the incinerator
while these assholes sat and drank beer
and provided fucking
commentary on my form.
- Well my body feels
just like really kind of
like firm, and like tight, and like GRR!
- And I do feel stronger.
I do feel more flexible.
I was definitely not flexible before this.
- Now I'm like, "Oh I can do this."
- I've definitely had to change my life.
That's not true.
I mean, I still eat like shit.
I still drink.
I just pay for them now.
- Oh hell (mumbling).
(grunting)
(grunting and laughing)
- Oh my god!
(yells)
- [Kenny] We're in the
third block of P90X,
which means less than 30 days to go.
And to be honest, I'm pretty
ready for this to be done.
Not 'cause I am not
happy with the results,
just 'cause it's killer every
single day, day in, day out.
- [Mallory] I am currently in a hotel room
in Europe, on vacation, but
since my colleagues and I
have decided to do this P90X challenge,
I am taking P90X with me on the road.
- Mallory, we miss you.
- Oh man, this fucking blows.
- Like, this is super easy.
Are we doing this wrong?
- [Daysha] I'm so done. Yeah.
(laughs)
90 days is too long.
But I'm definitely
excited to see my results,
and see, you know, did I do it?
Is this all muscle now?
- What's up Daysha, where you at?
- Listen, I ain't got
time to beat yo bitch ass.
We ain't done yet?
- 45 seconds.
- This is the last day of P90X and...
(all cheer)
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] We're
about to get our results.
- [Voiceover] Hopefully we improved guys.
- [Voiceover] I just want to
see like what's muscle now.
- [Mallory] Ready for
the finish line, guys?
Are you guys ready for the finish line?
- [Daysha] My goal was to lose body fat.
However, my personal goal
was to look like Beyonce.
Let's see.
- So my goal at the
beginning of this challenge
was just to basically lose body fat.
- My goal was to sustain.
- My goal was to gain muscle mass.
- Woah! That's super weird.
- So after 90 days, I lost a pound
of body fat.
- So, I lost 0.2 pounds of body fat
and I lost
what looks like 0.5 of muscle mass?
- Oh okay, so I gained
two pounds of muscle
and I also gained two
pounds of fat it looks like.
- It says that I gained
three pounds of body fat
and I gained 0.7 pounds of muscle?
- I'm about to look at a before and after
of what I used to look like
before and what I look like now.
Yup. I definitely look
liked I gained muscle.
There's definitely considerable
difference between the two.
Yeah, it looks like I
gained definition in my back
and my arms and on my whole front.
They say numbers don't lie
but today they fucking lie.
- Oh. I look different.
(laughs)
Woah. I look so different. Woah.
Also, I maybe got tanner.
Guys, I had so much back fat.
- Oh yeah.
I look a lot smaller
now than I did before.
I don't know what to
say y'all, but I mean,
at least I look better, so
that's all that really matters
to me at the end of the day.
Do you guys think I look like Beyonce?
- [Voiceover] Hell yes!
- [Voiceover] Hell yeah!
- I did it.
- Okay. Yeah.
(laughs)
I mean I definitely look bigger
pretty much everywhere a little bit.
Kind of like just uniform
change in the plus.
I'm happy with that.
(laughs)
I think I look good.
- [Voiceover] Moving forward I wanna
just exercise all day everyday.
- [Voiceover] I would say it's worth it.
- [Voiceover] Working out
three to four days a week
will seem like a cakewalk.
- [Voiceover] I'm starting
to think more about
what I could do diet-wise.
- [Voiceover] I'm gonna
miss doing the workouts
with them every week.
- I think we've all
grown together in this.
I think the camaraderie that
came along with it was great.
- Doing this with my friends
is kind of like the best part.
- I loved having my like fitness fam.
Like, that's what I love most about it.
- But I think we could all agree that P90X
was an excruciating,
soul-sucking experience.
(laughter in background)
And I am extremely happy that it's over.
Produces results, but if you do it,
you're out of your mind.
Good on you.
(intense music)